لقاء ريال مدريد وليفربول في ذهاب دور ال
16 من دوري ابطال اوروبا شهد العديد من
الارقام القياسيه نستعرض ابرزها فينيسيوس
جونيور لاعب مدريد البالغ من العمر 22
عاما هو اصغر لاعب يسجل هدفين على ملعب
ليفربول في اي منافسه اوروبيه منذ
الهولندي كرويف عام
وبعدما نجح في تسجيل هدف بمباراه امس صلاح
يعادل رقم ديروبا كاكثر اللاعبين الافارقه
تسجيلا في دوري ابطال اوروبا برصيد اربعه
واربعين هدفا صلاح ايضا اصبح اول لاعب في
تاريخ دوري ابطال اوروبا يشارك بالتسجيل
وصناعه الاهداف في ثماني مباريات مختلفه
لصالح فريق انجليزي هدف داروين نونيز بعد
مرور ثلاث دقائق وعشر ثواني من انطلاق
اللقاء هو اسرع هدف يسجله ليفربول على
ملعب في تاريخ مشاركته بدوري ابطال اوروبا
واخيرا كريم بنزيما مهاجم ريال مدريد اصبح
اول من يسجل سته اهداف في مرمى ليفربول في
المسابقات الاوروبيه بعدما احرز هدفين في
لقاء امس
[موسيقى]